welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss here with
mt we are talking about the falcon in
the winter soldier finale
we have so many questions uh coming out
of this episode we're gonna take them
live from our listeners on stereo and do
our best to
try to clear up any confusion we might
have or frame this episode on how we
should look ahead to
future mcu chapters any kind of
lingering questions you have
well first mt how you feeling i'm
feeling really
good i'm so glad that we finally got
this final episode of talking to the
winter soldier and we finally got to see
uh sam wilson as captain america and it
was just as beautiful as i thought it
would be and even more because he's a
majestic
majestic bird flying in the night sky
this is beautiful
it's beautiful it was a beautiful thing
let's take some questions from our
listeners here we go
well uh walmart cap finally got his
comeuppance
what do you think he's going from here
where do you think he goes
walmart that's such a funny way to
describe him
he is now us agent john walker this is
kind of where we thought he would end up
you know he has this like
darker shade of a suit uh in the comics
that's
what uh john walker's future is see
after going through a bout of
becoming captain america and then going
too far with it and being stripped of
that title
he ends up getting this new title of u.s
agent and he kind of becomes an assassin
um i just figure who is uh almost uh
not a kill for hire because he's usually
working with different groups whether
it's uh the
dark avengers but uh now it seems like
he is now gonna be tied in with whatever
vowels organization is i still think
it's gonna be some kind of thunderbolts
or dark avengers initiative yeah
uh that's gonna be tied in with
thunderbolt ross with zemo on the raft
and that gradually we're gonna see a new
team of assassins that's
put together to kill on behalf of
whatever shadowy government organization
that val is heading up what do you think
in t um i think we could be seeing this
like you know
like yeah the beginnings of a
thunderbolt situation but like sort of
like in a reverse
avengers sort of way because like uh the
avengers had steve rogers as their
captain america so maybe
john walker is this new thunderbolts um
captain america as figure that val is
trying to set up
they're probably gonna have us agent run
a couple of missions and then just be
like all right he can't do this on his
own
he needs a team let's just um you know
make this as the new
face of um i don't know avengering the
thunderbolts
um to do like those hard missions that
no one really wants to do
in in our own way walmart cap has a vast
array of possibilities in front of him
so
you know we'll we'll see what val's
going to do with him but i'm sure it's
going to be something real shady
and involves some killing yeah because
he's real good at that yes
yes he is let's take another question
here
do you think that the final scenes in
this episode of captain america and the
winter soldier
will be setting up a season two or more
movies in the future
um i think right now they've left the
door open to
either option uh i think directly these
final scenes were setting up
different futures for these characters
separately or on different adventures
in a show that won't be called captain
america in the winter soldier
i think this was kind of getting us as
we saw with one division from from a to
b
loki it sounds like was renewed for a
second season which is interesting but
both these first two shows i think were
conceived to be mini series that get
characters from
one step in their character journey to
the next as opposed to
like introducing a world that we're
gonna live in in a second season and
develop that world
but that said i could totally see this
world continuing to grow
just as the way it is like seeing what's
next for sharon carter as a power broker
or val with this you know seems like
thunderbolts initiative and john walker
um i i'd be interested in seeing a
second season of this show in particular
i i like sam and bucky's friendship i i
don't want them to separate
to be honest yeah i think we're gonna
get a season two
of like eventually down the line because
this show lends itself well to
having multiple seasons versus you know
one division that is more just like a
one and done type story
um but yeah i definitely don't think
that the post credits are setting up
a season two but like eric said it's
just like all right this is just our
this is just this point in the mcu and
then these characters that we've
introduced
will be um will play different roles in
upcoming films or mcu tv projects
but then as the mcu uh phase continues
along
if there is a need for a season two of
[ __ ] the linear soldier
that helps move along um the phase then
they will announce it but
as of right now like it's not like
obviously there's no announcement but
it's like but like it's not really an
imperative for a season two to happen
like you gotta think of these seasons
like sort of like sequels to like like a
movie like captain america
and like well captain america in the
winter soldier or falcon winter soldier
season two
is more like captain america in the
winter soldier two it's like this is the
sequel yeah so like you got to stop like
you start thinking it would be seasons
like
movies um in in a way because they are
just longer
movies told in episodic form um but
that's just
exactly hey you know i might be good at
finding easter eggs but i'm no wizard at
actually cooking eggs i mean look i can
warm eggs up it's just like to do an egg
correctly you got to kind of know what
you're doing so i need all the help in
the kitchen i can get and a great
non-stick pan is some of the best help
a chef can have the folks at my zen make
a great
non-stick pan i just love that they
don't even pretend that the coating will
last forever because no non-stick pan
lasts forever and anybody that's ever
owned one knows that
instead they make a great pan that lasts
two and a half times longer than its
competitors and at half the price
they use three layer dupont platinum
coating oh yeah supposedly they tested
it with super glue and super glue
slipped right off now i have cooked some
food that tastes like superglue so that
might actually come in handy
it is induction gas and electric stove
top compatible and oven safe up to 450
degrees so this can be your all-purpose
pan in the kitchen go to the link in the
description and use the promo code new
rockstars for
20 off your first order again go to the
link in description and use the promo
code new rockstars for 20 off your first
order
let's take another question hi guys yeah
first of all i just really like your
shows they're
really helpful especially the breakdowns
um so my question is pretty much
what what does the young credits mean
like what who did sharon carter call and
what does she mean
um yeah i'd really like to know i think
it's open to
suggestions yeah i agree i think it is
meant to be
a bit mysterious um it seems like uh
sharon carter is truly intended by the
show to be the power broker
uh i don't believe any of these things
to where it's like no that's a lie
because
ultimately think of it this way if she
is lying about being the power broker
or if you take her lack of uh verbally
saying that she is as
evidence that she is not um do you
really think the mcu is going to drag
out
that mystery over the next couple years
until we see her again
maybe in armor wars or secret invasion
no by the you know
next we have uh black widow we have
shang xi
we have the eternals we have doctor
strange and multiverse and madness we
have spiderman no way home we have thor
love and thunder
we have all these other big things that
we're gonna be excited about talking
about
they're not gonna be like also remember
how we never got exact
uh clarity on whether sharon was the
power broker or not
no she's just gonna be the power broker
next time we see her yeah right
we don't have to make mountains out of
molehills now we now got the answers
that the show is going to give us
yeah they they're pretty clear it's like
this is the power broker this is the
last thing if this is the last thing
that we see
of the show of sharon being like you
know implied as a power broker
she's 100 the power broker like i don't
think kevin feige really
would just be like ah just kidding
because like like again like they
already sort of did the same thing with
the mandarin like you can't
like you can only get one of those you
only get one like oh just kidding it's
actually this
so like i feel like they're yeah she's
she's definitely the power broker
yes and even when you do one of those
people get pissed when you do yeah you
know
like that's i think they learn their
lesson there like you can't keep
misdirecting people that way
but with uh who is she calling
uh i think she was talking to one of her
lieutenants or one of her criminal
contacts
she has that relationship with the
driver who picked her up in episode
three
or someone else in her network because
she has all those armed guards
um whoever her like right hand uh
man is uh she could have a connection
with
the ten rings uh with justin hammer's
organization
um the i don't think she was calling
zola though
but i never really expected to get a
zolo thing that was always my reach
you know what i think we need to do mt
now going forward we should
do our best to clarify to people when
our theories are our reach theories
and then our theories of what we think
will actually happen
and even falling short of that are our
lowest expectation of what the show will
give us
so like a three-tiered theory of
framework
look i never thought it was going to get
into princeton right that was my reach
theory
because eric will go to princeton uh and
then i had my safety school
and then i had well there's always the
local college that's down the street for
me
and so far the mcu has given us
community college
no i at the beginning of the series like
before the show even started i was
convinced
that zola was involved i was convinced
that's only was involved in one division
personally
um but we didn't see zola here i
definitely do think that zola is coming
back
personally uh to some degree though it
could be america's solo film
solo film or something but one of these
days
a solo that's a star wars story he's in
there
um let's uh take another question here
also
what do you think when val said
it's gonna get weird i'm thinking secret
invasion
set up chris i'm thinking you have
a hell of a voice my friend you should
be a radio announcer or a podcaster
you have such a good voice um yeah the
uh i think you're right i think she's
just kind of saying things are gonna get
weird
whether it's secret invasion whether
there are mutants involved uh
whether i think she means weird in that
it's not going to be as simple as these
are the avengers uh
and this is our clear hero lineup i
think she's saying there's gonna be a
lot of new heroes who join the scene
who are filling that power void and now
she's saying
in that world where the battle lines are
not clearly drawn between good and evil
we're gonna need someone like us agent
who doesn't necessarily
hold up the stars and stripes but can
still get the job done uh
so i think that's the idea of it um i
don't necessarily
know why in a world where there are
scrolls
we need u.s agent like i feel like in a
world where there are scrolls
in that kind of world you need clarity
and trustworthiness
more than anything because that's the
hard
work part about secret invasions you
don't know who you can trust
so maybe she was taking a cynical
interpretation of that
in a world where you don't know who you
can trust that your next-door neighbor
your best friend might be an alien
shape-shifter
that's where someone like john walker us
agent can succeed and excel
because no one trusts him anyway but the
job still needs to get done
yeah what do you think mt i think that i
really do like those points um
i i i tend to more see like i
definitely think that there's going to
be a thunderbolt situation set up with
john walker
um for sure with um with val but like i
do
think that val could want john walker
because she knows that he's crazy
and she knows that like you know his his
current path
so like i think that she is like all
right this guy's a human
so like i've seen some secret invasion
[ __ ] that i don't really like
i've seen some scrolls and like i want
to get rid of them so maybe
maybe one of the functions of the
thunderbolts is to weed out scrolls
and uh you know just get rid of them and
then kill them because like we don't
really want
aliens in our in our country you know
quote unquote um but like
i you know i this does seem like that
weird comment
really got me thinking about secret
invasion because you know you never know
who to trust like you just said like you
don't really know
um so it's like all right john walker
he's this guy who fiercely loves his
country
he fiercely loves um you know be he
loved being captain america for a time
and so it's just like all right i can
trust this guy because he's crazy
and like i can control this crazy um
he's crazy and he's powerful
so i do think that there could be
setting up a secreted major type
scenario but
who knows really it could be anything
yeah it's secret innovation
and all the above of like multiversion
collisions right because she seems to
know that that shield doesn't belong to
the us government and i've speculated
that could be
because she knows it comes from old cat
from an alternate timeline so if
val knows about alternate timelines yeah
she knows how weird things are about to
get
yeah um let's take
you think steve is on the moon
they referenced the moon again yeah i
love that that conspiracy theory came
back
um hey they brought it up twice multiple
people think this i think the show
intended that to be a joke like that
people believe that
uh and it's a joke i actually it was one
of my more favorite
dismissal jokes like he's just on the
moon people think he's on the moon
um for now i'm going to say yes i
believe he is on the moon
i believe there's some space base on the
moon either through what nick fury is
doing with the scrolls on that space
station
uh i don't think it will be the inhumans
though
uh but yeah i think we're looking at a
at a moon based kind of thing
i think that it would be fun for cap to
be on the moon
and as of this point it's our most
highly
likely plaza like i don't know it just
seems likely because they brought it up
again
um that he could be on the moon but
he could be anywhere like he could be
undercover he could be
um on the space station with uh nick
fury
um you know it's just gosh
i but i you know what i'ma say he's on
the moon too because
why not it's just fun it's a nice little
retirement place
why not right like i've been to a
different you know timeline
i've been to this this timeline i'm just
gonna go on the moon it's a different
change of scenery why not
it's fun yep yep yep uh let's take
another question
hi just wanted to ask what you guys
would change
about the falcon or i should say captain
america costume
if you could if anything i would
um i wouldn't change really anything
about it i mean i i kind of liked it i
thought it looked good
i'll say it's a little bright oh yeah
it's definitely no stealth suit it's
definitely very bright
um but i i think it looks super dope
it's it's so
comics accurate that i it's it's crazy
which is very different for um
for sam wilson because his falcon
costume
looks completely different from the
comics which which is for the better
let's let's get that out there because
it looks kind of ridiculous in the
comics let's be real because
of the time it was made um but yeah this
is very comics accurate i don't think i
would change
anything really maybe the goggles but
the goggles are 100 fine for me
but that is it for this falcon winner
soldier finale q in a we want to thank
all of our listeners on stereo for
giving us these great questions we're
going to be back this coming friday to
answer more questions
other loose ends other kind of remaining
questions you might have had about this
series and the way it's going to set up
the mcu going forward because yeah
there's a there's a lot of confusion and
we want to try to clear it up as much as
we can but we just want to give
ourselves some time to digest all of it
as always thanks to mt for joining me on
this follow him
mastertainment on instagram and twitter
follow me at ea boss on instagram
and twitter be sure to subscribe to new
rockstars here on youtube for breakdowns
of everything marvel and as always
support us by checking out one of our
many great merch options at
newarkstarsmerch.com whether it be this
anarchy assembled shirt or our amazing
zemo inspired design both of which
are running low on supply so you gotta
move fast thanks everybody
and we'll see you next time
[Music]
you